we have all seen this sign in
neighborhoods across the country they
warn drivers to slow down when children
are playing but you may not know the
fascinating International story behind
them to learn about their history we are
taking you to Japan the birthplace of
the running boy signs Lucy craft shows
us how they turn from a safety
precaution into a cultural phenomenon
in recent years child alert signs have
become a fixture of American
neighborhoods
but in Japan kid warning signs colorful
and even cartoon-like date back almost
half a century
hearing out of blind alleys lurking
behind utility poles and team tagging at
intersections for good measure one on
every corner
these city streets belong to an army of
painted plywood urchins
signaling motorists to slow down
everybody pays attention when there's a
running Boy sign this crossing guard
told us
this youngster said the sign tells
drivers to check both ways for kids I'm
in the birthplace of running boy the
city of higashiomi outside Kyoto it's
hard to overstate how much the people of
this town love these signs there are
literally thousands of them everywhere
known as tobidashi Boya running boy
signs date back to the 1970s when
Japan's Road fatalities hit an all-time
high
desperate residents turned to the
hisatas a family of signboard makers
instead of printed messages the hisatas
saw boards into the shape of a
seven-year-old poised on the brink of
dashing into traffic running boy has
helmet hair a determined mouth and beady
eyes painted in stoplight red and yellow
even his outfit says hit the brakes
a manager for the city's social welfare
Council overseas running Boy sign
campaigns there's even a line of
spin-off merchandise in higashiomi the
impish signs have taken on an almost
mystical significance
running boy has been around for so long
he said parents in areas without a
running boy think we might be an
accident waiting to happen
one local man was so inspired by the
sprinting Sprouts he occasionally suits
up and takes to the streets himself
flagging motorists as a larger than life
running boy
nowadays Japanese roads are vastly safer
than the Traffic Engineers like saitama
universities Hisashi Kubota say running
boy has nothing to do with it putting up
safety signs or painting warnings on
pavement may work for a few days he said
but after that studies show drivers just
ignore them what drivers Can't Ignore
are Road alterations like speed humps
that Force speeds down to around 20
miles per hour
to ensure drivers slow down the only
Shore method is constructing physical
infrastructure
Advocates can see the real benefit may
not be the signs themselves that getting
residents jazzed about traffic safety
for CBS mornings I'm Lucy Kraft and
higashiomi Western Japan
you know when when I was based in Asia
for CBS News I mean Japanese culture is
so fascinating kids go to school on
their own some of them as young as six
years old so these signs are critical
yeah it's important and I don't see the
difference in um explaining the children
remember when we were kids you know stop
look and listen or stop drop and roll
like the little things that they
reinforce ways before you cross the
street these signs are providing that
same service yeah you're right about
that